forget targeting the rich Joe Biden's
Army of IRS agents are coming after
Waiters Uncle Sam trying to stick it to
servers with a new program aimed at
catching people who Skip reporting tips
as income Jesse by principle you don't
tip but waiters do live off their tips
and it's sad that Joe thinks there's
just more blood to suck out of these
poor people when I was a Bellman um
that's all I did was make tips I think I
was getting minimum wage and then you'd
get cash maybe two hundred dollars a
night yeah valet and cars or helping
people like that
so if you tax that then I don't have any
beer money at 22. and what do I amount
to at that point you're hiring 87 000
IRS agents with guns to go after
waitresses while your son is under
investigation for tax evasion not
everybody has a sugar brother that can
Pony up 2 million to pay your back taxes
that you hid from Uncle Sam this is
ridiculous
ridiculous wow excellent point it is
ridiculous judge uh talk about punching
down going after our waiters and
waitresses especially after covid well
you know didn't he promise that he
wasn't going to do that with the 87 000
IRS agents it was only to go after the
billionaires but apparently the treasury
Inspector General for tax administration
says an estimated 30 percent of
employers with tip reporting agreements
hadn't reported tips worth almost 1.7
billion so here's the point they lied
shock yeah you know Harold in The Green
Green Room you said uh deserves them
right waiters and waitresses should try
getting better jobs the losers I thought
that was pretty harsh you said learn to
code didn't you yeah yeah
I was hoping we could keep that
conversation private but evident uh look
this is wrong and they should they
should they should publicly say this is
not what's going to happen this is not
what we should be spending money to do
you know Dana you were originally a
waitress before you got this job on the
five yeah I actually was a waitress yeah
yeah I loved that job yeah and how were
the tips at the time I did great yeah
you did great where what was the
restaurant Governor's part Governor's
Tavern Governor's Park Tavern in Denver
I don't think it exists anymore probably
not but anyway the IRS can wow those are
some strong at home I had to be fast I
don't know how that the transcribers are
going to do that but yeah there you go
well you know what I think we all came
to to a conclusion that this is stupid
yeah keep your hands off the waitresses
yes
and their money yes everyone and Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now